bienvenidos de vuelta en este vídeo
haremos un problema de momento pero en
dos dimensiones así que veamos lo que
tenemos muy bien entonces tenemos una
pelotita digamos la pelota que está en
color rojo y que tiene una masa de 10
kilogramos digamos que por alguna razón
se está moviendo hacia la derecha con
una velocidad de 3 metros sobre segundo
y golpea a una pelota ve que es la
morada de 5 kilogramos de masa muy bien
entonces al golpear digamos como como
cuando uno juega billar pues está esta
pelota roja rebota en esta dirección de
la flecha amarilla a dos metros sobre
segundo es el psuv héctor de velocidad y
su ángulo digamos el ángulo con el que
está rebotando respecto a su movimiento
original es de 30 grados entonces la
pregunta es cuál es la velocidad de la
pelota vez después del choque muy bien y
por supuesto cuando estamos hablando de
la velocidad del
de nuestra pelotita de estamos pensando
tanto en su dirección como en su
magnitud así que lo más fácil que puede
uno hacer para para pensar este problema
es pensar como si fueran dos bolas en un
juego de billar ok entonces a lo mejor
tú en este momento estarás diciendo oye
yo ya sé que de qué se trata la
conservación del momento y todas estas
cosas pero aquí tengo vectores y ángulos
y son dos dimensiones realmente cómo
puedo resolver este problema no es como
los que se han trabajado anteriormente y
lo que vamos a tener que hacer en este
caso es resolverlo por pedazos y de
hecho si uno quisiera resolver este tipo
de problemas en dos tres o cuatro las
dimensiones que tú quieras es
esencialmente la misma técnica lo que
tenemos que hacer es descomponer todos
estos vectores en sus direcciones
digamos xy sus direcciones y es decir en
la dirección horizontal y vertical
respectivamente y luego vamos a igualar
los momentos que surgen en cada una de
las direcciones y
ya sabemos calcular las como en los
casos anteriores por ejemplo si nosotros
descomponemos este vector digamos este
vector de dos metros sobre segundo bueno
quizás deberíamos iniciar con este
primero que es mucho más fácil pensemos
en el momento inicial en la dirección x
verdad del momento que lleva la pelota
verde y esto que después simplemente es
la masa por la velocidad por la
velocidad en su componente x verdad pero
esta vez este movimiento que lleva la
pelota roja es en dirección horizontal y
solo horizontal verdad entonces
multiplicamos la masa por la velocidad
en la dirección x que en este caso es 3
y nos da justamente 30 kilogramos por
metro sobre segundo que es las que son
las unidades del momento verdad ahora
bien si uno quiere calcular el momento
inicial pero en la dirección
pues uno tiene que notar qué
es 0 verdad porque no hay un movimiento
en la dirección vertical entonces este
es el momento inicial en la dirección x
el momento inicial en la dirección y el
momento conjunto entre la pelota y la
pelota ve después del choque deben
igualarse digamos en cada una de las
direcciones muy bien así que para poder
realizar esto vamos a utilizar
trigonometría y descomponer todos estos
vectores de tal suerte que podamos
analizar lo tanto en la dirección
horizontal como en la vertical y esto es
realmente el problema de momentos en
varias dimensiones descomponer en cada
una de las direcciones muy bien entonces
si no si si este vector lo vemos como la
suma de este vector
la suma de este otro vector entonces ya
podemos ya estar descompuesto en estas
dos direcciones y para resolverlo para
determinar bien cuál es cada uno de
estos vectores pues tendremos que
utilizar funciones trigonométricas
verdad y aquí sería bueno recordar el
soca tohá para poder determinar cuáles
son las relaciones trigonométricas que
me sirven verdad por ejemplo si este
vector le llamo el vector velocidad en
la dirección x es decir correspondiente
a la pelotita en la dirección x entonces
sabemos que este este lado es el
adyacente al ángulo
entonces si pensamos en el adyacente y
la hipotenusa que es otra otro dato que
tenemos que es 2 entonces sabemos que el
coseno del ángulo verdad
bueno podemos ver que la velocidad o la
componente de la velocidad en la
dirección x entre la hipotenusa que en
nuestro caso es 2 debe ser igual al
coseno coseno de 30 grados muy bien
ahora bien podemos simplemente despejar
y ver que la velocidad en la dirección x
de la pelotita es dos veces el coseno de
treinta grados dos veces el coseno de
treinta grados y uno rápidamente
recuerda que el coseno de treinta grados
es raíz de tres sobre dos verdad raíz de
tres sobre dos y si multiplicamos por
dos esto simple nos simplemente nos
queda 2 raíz de 3 entre 2 pues es
simplemente raíz de 3 verdad y esto es
en metros sobre segundo y aquí ya
tenemos cuánto vale esta componente
verdad en la dirección x es raíz de tres
metros sobre segundo vamos a ver qué
pasa con la dirección y si éste le
llamamos la velocidad de a
la dirección y pues simplemente
utilizamos ahora que bueno podemos ver
que este es el cateto opuesto entre la
hipotenusa nos da o bueno podemos
utilizar el seno de 30 grados verdad
entonces rápidamente uno ve que la
velocidad de la pelota en la dirección
ya es dos veces de la misma forma que en
el caso anterior dos veces el seno de 30
grados pero el seno de 30 grados es un
medio y si multiplicamos por 2 esto
simplemente nos da un metro sobre
segundo entonces éste desde un metro
sobre segundo y ya tenemos cada una de
las componentes de nuestra velocidad de
la pelota
muy bien ahora vamos a ver qué ocurre
con el momento verdad el momento debe
ser
igual al inicio que al final en cada una
de las direcciones
entonces si pensamos en el momento de la
pelotita y en la dirección y más el
momento
el momento de la pelotita ve en la
dirección y debe ser igual al momento
inicial en la dirección ya que en este
caso es 0 verdad en este caso debe ser 0
ahora cuál es el momento inicial de la
pelotita perdón en el momento de la
pelota en la dirección y pues sería la
masa que son 10 tendríamos 10 por la
velocidad que es 1 así que si lo dejamos
más el momento de la pelota ve en la
dirección y esto debe ser igual a 0
quiere decir que el momento de la pelota
ve en la dirección y es igual a menos 10
y por supuesto en las unidades que le
tocan que son kilogramos metros sobre
segundo verdad y aquí ya tenemos el
momento de la pelotita ve en la
dirección y sin embargo el momento
recordemos que es la masa por la
velocidad y la masa son 5 kilogramos
voy a utilizar esto son 5 kilogramos por
la velocidad por por la velocidad de la
pelota ve en la dirección ya que es
justo lo que queremos encontrar verdad
en este caso sería este esta componente
del vector la velocidad de la pelota ve
en la dirección de iu esto debe ser
igual a menos 10 entonces la velocidad
de la pelota ve en la dirección que es
menos 10 sobre 5 que es menos 2 metros
sobre segundo entonces esto es menos 2
metros sobre el segundo muy bien ahora
simplemente nos falta determinar cuál es
la velocidad de la pelota ve en la
dirección x y ahora también utilizamos
la conservación del momento verdad
porque tenemos que la con bueno el
momento en la dirección x de la pelota
es la masa la masa que es 10 por la
velocidad en la dirección x que es raíz
de 3 verdad
así que si lo calculamos el momento en
la dirección x de la pelota será masa
que son 10 por la velocidad que son raíz
de 3 y si sumamos el momento de la
pelota ve el momento el momento de la
pelota ve en la dirección x esto debe
ser igual a lo que ya habíamos obtenido
que son 30 verdad 30 que es este momento
inicial en la dirección x así que para
calcular esto vamos a utilizar la
calculadora muy bien vamos a vamos a ver
tenemos raíz de 3 así que tenemos 3 raíz
de 3 es 1.73 y si multiplicamos por 10
pues simplemente nos queda 17.32 verdad
y ahora vamos a cambiarle el signo
verdad le cambiamos el signo porque
vamos a pasarlo restando así que si
ahora tenemos
30 - 10 veces la raíz de 3 esto nos da
12.67 podemos dejarlo como 12.7 muy bien
así que la el momento de la pelota ve en
la dirección x es 12 puntos 7 metros más
bien kilogramos metros kilogramos por
metros sobre segundo verdad
ahora bien el momento otra vez es masa
por velocidad así que si queremos saber
la velocidad
la velocidad de la pelota ve en la
dirección x hay que dividir 12.7 entre
la masa que son 5 así que si tenemos 12
puntos 7 entre 5 eso nos da a 2.54
254 metros sobre segundo muy bien así
que este de aquí la velocidad debe en la
dirección x es 2.54 metros sobre segundo
muy bien y así podríamos incluso obtener
el ángulo simplemente debemos utilizar
el arco tangente del cociente de estos
dos valores verdad pero bueno eso es un
poco más complicado y lo haré quizás en
el siguiente vídeo pero lo que sí
sabemos ya son las componentes x
de nuestra pelota b nos vemos en el
próximo vídeo